[Music]
get your freak on news love her she
hasn't aged people at all that era was
great with Missy Luda and Busta that's
music videos all time show us one of the
sweatiest outfits made out about ja Rule
dude oh and Ashanti just seeing that the
VMAs really I don't like John I always
thought he was a fake-ass thug but I
loved his music he came out like a fake
ass Tupac like it was too slow for me
did he even want you up with the bandana
like Tupac all 50 ended that feels good
Nelly has his own style though this is
all and so he's like Miss South and he
read the South I went to a concert last
month and the roots are playing and then
busted came out of nowhere and I lost my
[ __ ] you said you're gonna bite ya Wow
di-did yeah give me some oh you're
rubbing it in gave me some Bob what was
the article submitted by a Gio over
David
we're like arrow arrow Guadalajara has
changed its laws to allow sex in public
yes your hometowns what's your birth
that's crazy like what why is this so
important that it went to you know and
then they voted on la why would we want
it why I'm pretty sure water has other
problems to work on exactly why that's
this law because they don't want to put
people in jail for some dumb they want
to do for the party
or just I just pictured a bunch of
Mexican hipsters like motion expression
of love should not be illegal you can't
do the Mexican access to Argentinian you
can't but you guys do too much oh yeah
so rape in public is cool too now yeah
rape is Lee will rape as a type of sex
to consensual hipsters Leonard a type of
sex it's not no wait rape is a crime
rape is rape it's an assault it's not a
type of sex they made it legal wouldn't
be a crime anymore
hypothetical Oh the sex in public is a
crime yeah I guess so they made rape
legal sure you're right look I don't
want to back up Bart
all right he's out on his own he's out
up there I'm just trying to understand
the house and just the question the law
is just public sex that's all it is
nothing else like if they drink a little
bit too much tequila and then they're
like hey let's do something risky and
then she's like I don't know it's
illegal it goes not anymore public
nudity ban any people I know that's did
not arise some more but the cop could
also just turn a blind eye instead of
going through the whole process that's
the thing though I mean yeah you could
easily say that but if they're really
trying to go by their policies in their
laws they're not going to turn every
drugs legal right if I caught someone
having sex in public and I called the
police if it's illegal they have to go
and arrest them because I called right
yeah car driving around blocking them go
they're doing their job they can't do
that cuz they have to make a report and
all that because I'll check up on them
and say hey you're not doing your job so
this law did pass because of like what I
said earlier like they they want the
cops to focus on the important things
yes
is exactly why I wanted but they also
say like it's pointless to criminalize
people I just can't afford a hotel or
whatever say men's days better I just
feel like I'm a like a Mexican town hall
meeting and I'm like why do I imagine
them Nacho Libre Church your honor three
years ago I had five tickets because
mere lorina was making love on the beach
oh well I thought the cities even near
the beach two lovers making love on the
beach you know romantic so now like if I
just go grocery shopping two guys come
on
not near the [ __ ] fruits please so
they did say that as long as there isn't
a third party complaining about it then
it's fine but as soon as someone raises
complaints and that's when you gotta go
[ __ ] somewhere else yeah in a dark alley
okay got it and they can't be doing it
near like obviously like we're kids are
old parks okay got it
I don't think people are just gonna do
the time you think well I think they
have been doing it oh so that's why the
police have been spending a lot of time
and effort on these people so they may
pass this law so they could be like all
right just [ __ ] all you want let's focus
on important I'm assuming they're like
teens or someone that can't [ __ ] at home
yeah so they're like [ __ ] at the park
or in an alley and they get caught and
then they get in trouble or inside cars
all [ __ ] in the cars yeah super it's
like pretty still pretty Catholic [ __ ]
yeah do it only hard every time when I
used to live in Mexico because I lived
in Mexico for a year when I was fifteen
I wasn't born there a lot of people
think that but when I lived there my
grandma she was like super conservative
but if I talk to any boys like they
would come visit my grandma's house
don't you like are you gonna be [ __ ]
up put you in a turtleneck not what
those laws are not but maybe in 2018 now
I am cuz it's not illegal
go ahead yeah yeah what's that mean
because I just heard kegels no compare
this go hair okay go ahead I never knew
yeah we don't have a [ __ ] you bear so
many other ones like yeah owners in the
first place underneath to the [ __ ]
Donna blanket you know Guadalajara is a
major city but I can't help but imagine
like a yes yes what's happened in my
head yeah that always trips me out when
I see that portrayal of Mexico in the
media because I only grew up with going
to the major cities yeah my family like
my mom's side is from Tijuana and my dad
sites from willing a hideout which are
major cities and never saw like the
desert in Mexico that the movie it's
always old or - when I think of Mexico -
I imagine like that remember the three
amigos oh yeah with Chevy Chase and
Steve Martin yeah zona you know in the
Old West like watch the Alamo or
whatever like it's like this old-school
like tumbleweed and then like Mexicans
in the church like it's kind of like
nacho libre right it's like that every
ball knows yeah but when I think about
it it's all it's back in the pattern why
you think about that why cuz you guys
haven't seen my world I had a vlogs you
should go check them out they're
beautiful while that blog
even if I been there they would have
read you yeah not down yeah we don't
know yeah I would a couple more years
that's true it is kind of crazy
what if you go like extra south then you
go to Salvador El Salvador's I wonder if
you go even south from Colombia Colombia
we just jumped a big way cuz the most
dangerous is Colombia to the US because
that's where the drug route is but what
if you go under that then does it matter
like yeah like Argentina there's still
like spots they're sketchy spots my
family's an Argentine there's it's kind
of like even in my head if we don't have
a little try to be ethnically whiteboy
[Laughter]
ancestry said he's 0.02 no one knows
Mike's I continue I know they think I'm
the Jewish kid yeah baby you're Jewish
yeah just this schnoz the Avenue telling
schnoz OH
which you are Italian I am and you try
to order a bagel this morning no I did
it that was me okay you brought me to
Starbucks what are you gonna order a
[ __ ] margarita pizza [ __ ] Alfredo
wait tell me about I didn't get where
we're from super small it's like cattle
like in it's pretty dangerous too but I
know I think it's just cuz it's like is
it a town yeah kind of when I picture
Argentina I picture white Mexicans
Mexican not what everyone else see I
picture the rodeo Mexicans like wait
like I got horses with like like a
flannel shirt and like that like a
cowboy
that's what then they're all white oh
that's nice there's a lot of cows
everywhere and that's it so one Osiris
is like New York or something like it's
literally top ten biggest and don't cry
for me Argentina that movie the girl
maybe that's why I think yeah wine is
dick yeah but it is kind of like even
like Mexico we have like more European
looking Mexicans and you have more like
yeah it's that where the weather girls
come from I mean there's fun Mexico
almost everyone well from what I heard
is that almost everyone that you see on
Mexico television they come from they're
fine they look like they don't miss no
sauce no no that we're caught like
people that are from well how do I
caught up with us
because they're spicy like every town
has like their their thing so my dad's
from Durango and they call them the I
think Tallulah's I think there's a lot
grannies which is like the what do you
call her yeah I want a cool name people
from Mexico City they call chillin goes
what's that mean
is it Mexico City the sketchiest right I
don't know if that's a slang though I
don't know if that's the thing the spicy
mango spicy mango but they're the ones
that you see that are like darker and
shorter oh oh the ones that sell roses
off the freeway I love them they're cute
I don't know I don't know they could be
Guatemalan too which is completely
separate from Mexico I'm a lot of moans
in Mexico know something about
Guatemalans from oh no cuz I was talking
about how you know you're seeing like is
that the shorter dark the ones so when
you go through Mexico there's ten people
sell you blankets roses guitars I was
wondering if those were Mexicans or the
guava yeah they're Mexican but they're
just they just look more into their the
chilling goes I don't know I just know
from that region yeah that's what I know
that I feel like every Asian house has
that Tijuana blanket the big thick right
before you come back in I think exactly
should wore green tablets you I don't
know if you guys have I don't know if
Japanese have that I grew up with it too
oh no I mean like but but it was a
Tijuana blinking like we got it from
Tijuana or the swap meets yeah I hated
those things when I was at kicks and
every time I had to make my bed in the
morning it to fold them they're heavier
[ __ ] I had to stand on the bed and
there's nothing throw it that [ __ ] was
hard though
[Music]